it's been two months since Apple
released their iPhone 14 lineup and I
got my 14 pro Max and I love the phone
it is amazing but there are certain
things that absolutely grind my gears
and the thing is some of these can be
fixed by software While others are
Hardware related that are bummers and
with some of these I've actually found
workarounds that I'm going to be sharing
with you guys to help you out with that
said let's Jump Right In now the first
one really hurts me and that is the fact
that these screens seem to scratch a lot
easier than the iPhone 13s and the 12s
even though all three of them had
ceramic shield now shortly after I got
them I got one scratch then another and
I'm extremely careful with my phones and
the screens now before you guys say you
should have a screen protector well I
didn't have screen protectors with all
my previous phones and they seem to do
better so I did a little research and so
many people are posting that these
phones are scratching very quickly very
easily whereas their iPhone 13 12 lasted
a year or two and looks better than a
new iPhone just after a couple of weeks
and even worse some people were getting
scratched ones out of the box and other
people replied saying yes I'm getting
the same thing now I don't know if Apple
just changed how this glass is made
there was one post where even the back
glass was scratched while having a crate
case on there uh maybe they cheapened
out to have better profit margins I know
what's happening but because of that I
actually bought AppleCare on this iPhone
when I never had before because I'm so
careful I've never needed it I went
ahead and subscribed because I'm gonna
have to be able to replace a screen down
the line most likely so I would say if
you're buying a new one consider getting
a screen protector even if you really
don't like them like I do now the second
one is display dimming now yes this has
happened for years but this year Apple
said that they included a thermal system
to keep the phone cooler now that is
true and the 14 pro Max does do a better
job at it but it does still dim now with
the 14 pro which I'll also talk about in
just a bit with another issue this thing
actually dims even more so than the
regular 14. uh when I when we're doing
our tests when we're doing gaming I'm
honestly really surprised by how much it
dims because of that powerful a16
processor the cooling system is
overwhelmed so that would recommend if
you're on the fence to go for a 14 pro
now the third one is the magsafe
charging speed now I'm somebody that
loves wireless charging I don't even
have like the cable in my room to charge
up but in times where I do need a charge
and we'll talk about battery life in a
bit when I pop it on the speed just
isn't that great now when Apple launched
it we were so excited because we were
finally going to get fast wireless
charging on the iPhone but in my insane
charging comparison I found that their
15 watt magsafe actually wasn't that
much faster than using a 7.5 watt
standard charger because it slows down
to 6 Watts not long after you start
charging so even though C seems like
it's a lot faster it's not and that's
just because Apple slows it in town
which brings me to this video sponsor
ESR which makes my favorite budget three
in one charger their Halo lock wireless
charger with cryo boost now the price is
unbelievably low for the quality and not
only does the airpods charger have
magnetic alignment but since you used
your own Apple watch Puck you'll get
faster charging than budget built-in
options their cryobboost Tech has a fan
so your wireless charging won't slow
down due to heat say if you're watching
videos or doing anything else and having
active cooling increases battery
longevity because unlike other wireless
chargers your phone stays really really
cool and I was shocked by how nice the
thing is especially with the real
aluminum parts the adjustable angles and
the included power adapter whereas other
budget options are plastic and often
don't come with a power brick esr's
magnets are stronger and the fan is
quiet but can also be shut off along
with the lights Apple's Puck can only
charge one device and belkins which has
three costs 150 dollars so I think it's
the best three month charger for the
price check it out using the links below
now like I said I love macsafe and if
you're charging at night it doesn't
matter and with that you can just get
like an ESR one if you're not going to
be waiting for it to charge but I would
love them to maintain that faster speed
when you do need it to charge fast like
for example you have OnePlus that can
charge your phone in 45 minutes when you
need it but then at night it will charge
slower because you don't and it doesn't
want to add the extra heat now with that
we have reverse wireless charging now
this phone is capable of it but Apple
won't let us use it now I know that most
of the time it is not something that's
needed but hear me out on this the
hardware has been in the iPhone since
the iPhone 11 but was never turned on
and the first and only accessory that
can use it is the maxafe battery pack
that came out not long ago now if you
have the battery pack on your phone but
you plug your lightning cable into the
phone itself not the pack well that'll
actually charge your phone faster and
then it will reverse wirelessly charge
the pack so you have the benefit of
having it there and both will charge up
but other than that you can't use that
feature anywhere else now in the last
two months I've had multiple situations
where it would be so nice to have that
once my airpods were dead and I didn't
have access to a charger so I was out of
luck and I was doing a bunch of stuff
outside without using my airpods now I
would have loved it if I could just
place them on my iPhone and charge them
now if you say that's because it is
inefficient well with Apple's battery
pack that first limited to 5 Watts but
then nine months later they upped it
because people weren't happy and it was
slow and you rather have the extra speed
even if we had a 50 inefficiency in my
14 pro Max would lose 25 battery if you
fully charge the airpods in the case but
in case of an emergency in about five
minutes or so you can get an hour of
listening and that's enough to get you
out of a bind and with that they already
added macsafe alignment to the case of
the airpods now other times we're to
revive friends or my wife's dead phone
if they needed to make a call or check
messages and be so nice to be able to
you know plug it up charge charge up a
few percentages and check it or be able
to charge other accessories like an
Apple Watch since they have small enough
batteries where you don't have to drain
your phone that much I just wish that
Apple didn't lock down all the great
Hardware with their software now the
next one has been the lack of the Sim
slot now I wish Apple just kept it here
in the states just like they did in
other countries at first I had issues
with calls not coming in and errors but
after that it stopped now what I'm
having is just the lack of ability to
quickly pull out a Sim put it into
another phone that I'm testing or put it
into a tablet you have to transfer it it
takes a lot longer you just don't want
to do it and with the 14 plus I had to
go in and make multiple calls and then
go into a local spot go through multiple
people to try to get it set up because
of other issues so if they would have
just kept it there like they did in
other countries that would just been a
lot easier for me having no sim slot has
been all negatives with no positives at
all now the next one is the dynamic
Island now I actually absolutely love
the dynamic Island I love that it's very
convenient but we were here two months
later and not many companies already
adding anything to make it useful and I
want them to do that uh so the island is
there itself and the negative is the
fact that it cuts into video uh it you
know it's more noticeable compared to
the notch but I would love it if Google
Maps would allow it to show turn-by-turn
navigation there just like Apple Maps
has and so recently I've actually been
using Apple Maps uh because it is
convenient when I have just set up on my
stand now as you know I have done a ton
of testing with the cameras with every
scenario that you can even against a pro
camera setup that was around nine
thousand dollars and the raw looks
amazing that we have such a huge
difference between shooting regular
photos and the 48 megapixel Pro raw not
only in detail but the ability to have
much better highlight roll off it looks
a lot more natural now I've complained a
lot that you can't shoot 48 megapixel
compressed files and that the file sizes
instead of being three megabytes or
maybe up to seven it's like 75 megabytes
and apple won't let you just shoot to
that now my workaround has been to use
the shortcut to be able to select them
and convert them that's been the best
way that I've found so now I'm shooting
you know a ton of shots doing Pro raw
because it looks so good now other than
just letting us shoot it without having
the conversions I would love to be able
to do portraits in full quality now
Apple doesn't like to have uh features
that take a lot of time like processing
later or that won't be able to show you
the portrait ahead of time but a lot of
Androids do that and I think most of us
would take the trade off of having to
see the image later but get the best
quality now with that I also found that
these new Pro iPhones are doing things a
little bit differently when I did the
comparison against the 13 Pro and 12 Pro
there are some times where the images
didn't look better at all and sometimes
when they actually looked worse and not
just with the main camera and what I
found is the fact that they actually
will not go into night mode they'll just
take a regular photo and that's even
without having the prefer a faster
shutter option turned on now that just
means that you're not getting the better
quality uh because you just press and
take one image now once again for
Android sometimes you take five seconds
or seven seconds when it did the
comparison against the Samsung and the
pixel and that helps them so what I
found is a workaround is the ability to
just go down press that little button
for a night mode drag the slider and
then manually enable night mode but
thing is it just doesn't stick so if you
want the best quality images you have to
do that and there's no way to kind of
enable it to prefer night mode in the
settings and after talking about all
these photos I have to talk about the
lightning Port now I recently made a
video saying I don't want USBC on the
iPhone I want something better and
that's because Apple at this point is
purely I don't know if it's just greed
for money or what but they're limiting
this to be 10 times slower than what we
had in the 12.9 inch iPad in 2015 even
though we actually have the need for it
with large you know raw files we have
prores to back stuff up they're just
capping it and they don't have to be
doing that to me it just doesn't make
sense in you know the end of 2022 almost
2023. now if they do stick with the USB
type-c port I really hope that they're
going to do Thunderbolt like we had a
recenter leak that will fix all of those
issues but Apple just intentionally
wants to keep you using iCloud and
paying for that or at least using
airdrop which they had in their document
so they showed off so that you have to
have a Mac and you're preferring you
know to stay in their ecosystem now the
next one is the fact that the screen is
still too bright often times in the dark
now we talked about the Dual sensors and
people said that it would adjust over
time but it is still brighter in almost
every scenario than before now all Apple
has to do is give you a compensation
adjustment slider in the settings if you
prefer a brighter or darker and that
will also help with battery life I
complained about battery life being
really bad so much so that I had to go
with the 14 pro Max instead of my
preferred smaller size because the
regular 14 pro would die hours earlier
compared to the last generation now
thankfully it has gotten a lot better
and with iOS 16.1 there's been a nice
jump on YouTube idevice help compared
the last four generation of phones and
the 14 pro Max gained just over one and
a half hours of battery life with just
the software update and optimizations so
what's there to complain about well
there's not that much it's definitely a
great thing but that test did not
account for the display being brighter
or the xdr that can get super bright
outside or they're always on display
mode so overall we're still looking at
about one to two hour lower battery life
compared to last year and that's
something that I would gladly take for
these extra features but with that even
though I would like to have the 14 pro
not the pro Max I still have to go with
the pro Max because I do have a lot of
background tasks that need to be on and
the battery life just will not keep up
with the full day this year like it did
last year so there you guys go those are
my frustrations things I wish Apple
didn't do and what they did do along
with some helpful tips there go ahead
and click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
thank you